foreign
people welcome to another episode of I'm
sure it's commentaries live from our
respective homes today we're talking
about Elvis uh we're gonna show you the
honest trailer we're going to stop and
start and give us our behind the scenes
thoughts and feelings we'll show you
some deleted scenes we'll answer your
questions and comments so type those
into the chat right now and we'll tease
you with next week's honest trailer uh
it's gonna be a nice one um oh yeah I'm
working on it yeah I'm enjoying it uh
there's your clue I'm actually enjoying
this
but people are like I'm enjoying this uh
Danielle's applying a Fresh coat of
jelly to the lens look I got a Barbara
Walters it up all right
Hulk more smoke machines uh we're at
home Lonnie you feeling okay I didn't
have it sorry I hopped on the call late
uh Lonnie doing okay is that why you're
okay okay good all right I'm a little
under the weather this week it's not
covered it's not like you guys are gonna
catch but Ryan's doing me a solid and
letting me broadcast from homes good
well yeah I would I I covered or not
like I don't want the sniffles I can't
afford having the sniffles right now
that could derail everything I don't
think I'm I don't think I'm catching but
just to be safe why not why why risk we
can talk about Elvis from home
um
I uh I resisted watching or doing this
movie probably longer than we should
have um Danielle you've been on the
Elvis train for a long time
um beating the Elvis drum whereas I was
like do I have to and that's because I
have um never enjoyed a baz luhrman
movie
no I do have not even a begrudging
respect for it I have a respect for it
um I appreciate the craft and the like
the Broken Clock being right twice we're
like wow that was amazing uh but just
the rest of the time
it is
and it's a weird comparison because I
love Tim and Eric but he's very like Tim
and Eric to me where I think it's great
like 15 minutes at a time like 15
minutes a bit of baz is great and like
Tim Eric's awesome show there's a reason
Adult Swim shows are like 11 to 15
minutes because like that style gets
grading after like two and a half hours
like this movie did to me disgust uh
yeah baz can be very it's like uh it's
just very it's a lot
um it is a lot happening like I went
back and watched the beginning of Moulin
Rouge and I was like I could only have
followed this when I when this came out
when I was a kid like I can't my eyes
don't do that anymore to be able to
follow all of like the edits and the
Quick Cuts but I yeah no I
unabashedly love this movie I know and
I'm in the minority here Ryan uh who's
on the call listening in uh said he
loved it Lana you really like this movie
right
Danielle please keep gushing about Elvis
no well because here's I want to be very
clear you know how I have two movie
lists
this is this is on that oven this is not
this is on the list where I put like my
break in twos it's where my Supergirl is
it's on that list but who it is like a
rocket up that list we should do a
montage if it go another joke
with a bullet it is getting up there
um I'm spinning around the number one
spot fearing inside an eyeball and then
into the starship Enterprise turns into
a roulette table Yeah
a corrugated metal Shack and up into a
blue singer's mouth Yes yes it's uh wow
uh because I remember the first time I
watched it and I sat down and I was
trying to explain it and I was like I
don't know if this is good or bad but I
like it too much for it to be the first
one yeah that's exactly what I said yeah
that's for sure I feel like bass lemon
is so good at I'm going to show you a
place you would like to be in in and go
it almost has that sometimes when you go
to like a Broadway show and more than
I'm super compelled by the story it's
just like it's an inviting environment
it's just a fun place to be everybody's
singing and dancing it's bright it's
colorful movement and we're so used to
you know I don't want to pick at it
people get mad when you pick specific
examples but we're so used to like four
characters standing around in front of a
pretty backdrop talk talk talk talk talk
it's it's lovely to see a filmmaker that
is all about being cinematic and motion
and excitement and like in Great Gatsby
where they're just all they're doing is
driving from Long Island or into the
city but it's like there's a car next to
him where there's a guy with a trumpet
outside the car just like playing a
concert down the freeway to like I I
love that element of baz luhrman movies
and this movie is like that where it's
just constant energy and and it's always
compelling as you he has a history of
the career and life of Elvis Presley
what is this it's crazy like it's it's
weird it's I can't get over maybe it's
an old man thing but I can't get over
being like here's an Elvis Presley
biopic and then nothing in it feels
accurate through the light and Times of
Elvis Aaron Presley I just I don't know
yeah it feels like this weird past
like it's like a Broadway musical
inspired by the life of Elvis Presley I
mean I think we're all ignoring well I
think we do point out in the trailer is
like the obvious metaphor or kind of
like driving Central conceit of this
movie and I think as filmography is the
carnival and like the spectacle The Snow
Job if you will yeah he's just giving
you a bunch of Razzle Dazzle and like
you he he's robbing you but also leaving
you with a smile
um at the same time so I think that he's
like he's like the serial killer
confessing like I gave you all the clues
Mr policeman in this movie gave you all
the clues my boy yeah my boy my watch is
gone
that boy took my wallet when he was
that's that's what Elvis is to me is
what you're what you're looking at well
the boy the carnival boy steals your
wallet and watch uh and with that said
no job in some ways we've we all got
snow jumped pretty good on this one um
so let's watch the trailer where Elvis
we'll stop and start
I can't believe we got through that
whole intro at the name Tom Hanks well
don't say its name it'll appear fast and
loose approach to Shakespeare The Great
Gatsby and uh France
so when Warner Brothers asked him to
make a big Elvis biopic he said radio 20
music videos stick together by a bog
monster how about a dojo cat song in
there as well too late already in bad
hands Elvis
I was insistent right off the bat that
we make John do his uh Australian accent
yeah it's pretty good I don't remember
when we had him do that before but
that's stuck in my head that John could
do a really good Australian boy yeah and
is it the same as his Korg uh from last
week would you be the judge this guy
John is a professional voice man and he
could distinguish between Sydney and
kiwi that's right
I'm taking on faith that he can because
I cannot I cannot but but John can't
yeah that's why he's the Epic voice guy
yeah I'm just a regular voice yeah
yeah
um I did watch my first interview with
with baslerman seems like a nice uh
Aussie guy and he's pretty excitable
he's actually exactly how you would have
imagined if somebody said bazlerman is a
excitable Australian man like oh yeah
there he is yeah that's uh yeah so I
think I think it's pretty spot on but I
can't tell Australian accents apart no I
certainly can't tell like oh that's a
earth man
I'm not picking out Melbourne versus uh
the the the Outback or whatever right no
I I get the Peewee there's a it's a
little different when you go when you go
to Newton
uh Richard Roxborough who we saw him
there he's the Duke in Moulin Rouge he's
like the bad yes yes he's also Vernon
Presley Elvis's dad and this I looked up
his filmography I forgot how many
classic random ass things that that guy
has had quite a career the one that
stuck out to me is he's Dracula in Van
Helsing remember that band oh nice yeah
I totally I forgot he was the bad guy in
that doesn't strike me as a Dracula uh
no he's he's always a chameleon it's
always like he's the Duke of France and
Moulin Rouge and then he's Dracula and
he's Elvis's dad he's like what a
chameleon that guy is awesome oh great
uh one of the great that guys in yeah
yeah cool that guy all right let's keep
going slips in this thing's metal
Underpants in tune Austin Butler
delivers a breakup performance as the
original quarked up white boy goated
with the sauce but don't get me wrong
this Nickelodeon kid is all grown up all
right all right hey you want a fish taco
he can see he can dance and he can Flash
the most powerful doomy eye since Nala
gave the green light to Simba
[Music]
in some of these he is looking at
Colonel Parker or his mother
you got it bro I'm trying to do a
trailer here
okay okay maybe just one little kiss
um look I don't really care about Elvis
uh but I'm so excited for uh him to play
a fade router in Dune too I gotta say
after seeing this I think that that is a
really really good choice I think he's
gonna nail it I'm psyched
oh yeah I think he's gonna do a good job
and I want to see him like do that but
menacing
um because you can see this this kid is
like fully fully com he's a grown man I
don't know why I say kid everyone's a
kitchen now he's like 30 now don't worry
he's like 30. um but yeah he really
really committed to the character and it
does sometimes slip into being almost an
impersonation but he rides the line and
it's one of those things where it's like
how much of that is him and how much was
bass because how much would he have like
maybe taken a couple of steps off of off
of the gas but bass was like Nick you're
winning you know yeah totally uh I think
he's it's a great performance it they
don't make Elvis much of a character
that like he doesn't we we rarely get a
lot of insight into what's going on in
his mind other than I really like gospel
music and boy am I sad about the death
of Martin Luther King as we all would
but
um but the movement like in terms of
physically embodying Elvis during all
these performances and just like feeling
like we're seeing Elvis on stage it's
amazing really like he's doing uh
they're doing those like internet you
know side by side comparisons and I mean
he's nailing these famous performances
but it really is impressive to see to
see him like doing all those on stage
performance sequences those are the
that's the best part of the movie
because he's really embodying the king
that we remember from you know Vintage
Film well you know I mean he doesn't
have to worry about playing a character
with agency so he could just like really
commit to all of the other things yeah
it doesn't make me wish they had done a
little bit more and I guess maybe modern
audiences don't even know these movies
and that's why they didn't bother but it
would have been fun to see him recreate
like moments for Blue Hawaii or Clambake
or Speedway or being in Las Vegas some
of these really cheesy Elvis movies
just because he's doing such a good job
yeah that would have been nice
um well I'm psyched to see him uh duel
uh Timothy Charlemagne with a Chris
knife in the middle underwear it's gonna
be great yeah just it's gonna be a real
Duel of the lips twinkle
what the [ __ ] is that I was just a boy
from Huntington West Virginia is that
Tom Hanks
me Colonel Tom Parker a Monster who
should be banished to The Uncanny Valley
he crawled out of he looks like someone
left Colin Farrell's Penguin on a hot
radiator and sounds like I don't know
wado making fun of the Trade Federation
it's somehow offensive to everyone there
was that fairy Intel wedding and the
honeymoon on Frank Sinatra's jet
especially to the guy who actually
prepped for his role watch this Carney
swindler never let the truth get in the
way
um that to me is what I think put this
mainly puts this movie in the other list
[Laughter]
explanation is that they think it's
funny they just have to think it's funny
because they can't think it's good
because it's not a good impression of
the guy
um
that's a terrible impression then they
had that Syria Taylor wedding he sounds
like you know when you're a kid and you
make up fake languages so that people
don't know what you're saying yeah it's
like when like twins have their own
language
it's also pretending that the Revelation
that he's not from Huntington Virginia
and he's actually from uh the
Netherlands is like a shocking like they
save it for the end and it's like oh my
God the ultimate betrayal and yet Hanks
is doing this accent where it's like he
sounds like Paul verhoven from the very
beginning it's like he's like why are
you doing a Dutch accent if you want
that to be a Twist that we don't see
coming
and how I mean this movie really thinks
Elvis is dumb
like it's not even just dumb it's like
he's like a child like
yeah simpleton almost
because how would he
oh uh oh Spencer will be back uh but uh
so I'll I'll just keep talking um
because how would he have not known like
as soon as you meet that guy like oh no
this person is uh obviously not from
Huntington West Virginia it's
everything in baz world is like that
next level of it's a little cartoony
it's over the top it's almost like he
doesn't trust you to get it and he you
need the movie to be like
here's what happened Elvis not very
Savvy this guy came in and took
advantage like you can't imply the guy's
just got to be like say in voice over
like I came in and took advantage of Mr
Elvis Presley you know like we won't get
it unless it says it
yeah there's that fantastic moment where
um his mama and we'll get into that
relationship I think a little bit uh
where uh Elvis's mom was like I just
feel like he might come between us baby
and then you see
and then all of a sudden literally Tom
Hanks is sitting um at a casino and he
turns around like the end of Thriller
where Michael Jackson turns around and
he's like yes on a bet yes
it was so good
so good Ryan oh I'm back wait wait did I
just get replaced by Ryan no no no we're
unironically praising the movie I'm
sorry you guys no no stick around stick
around
uh I guess we'll just keep on to each
other though what were you talking about
Tom Hanks still yeah we were talking
about Tom Hanks yeah it's it's just like
cartoonishly like Elvis in the movie
can't see through it and and we're not
blaming real life Elvis but Elvis in
this movie it's like Elmer Fudd falling
for the eighth Bugs Bunny guy a lot of
Charlie Brown a beautiful woman that's
the rabbit you've been chasing all
afternoon
so convincing now could you tell Tom
Hanks to change though like I guess baz
has the stature too but like who's gonna
tell Tom to not do that if they want to
trust it I have to trust that Tom's
first instinct was to do you know a
natural a real voice a natural voice of
like a Dutch guy or whatever he is and
then baz was like that might make it
weird
Pinocchio at the same time I think we
have to start yeah I think he's picking
these projects okay okay
look he's still uh
longer assumed that he is he is brief
for Chet because that's all I can say oh
yeah you were on you are on watch sir
two years ago yeah I was
I was definitely in the Hank's defense
camp but now I'm starting to slip I
don't know yeah he's got some explaining
to do he's testing us
um we'll see all right keep going we
have a good story sand the edges off
Elvis to make it more palatable and it's
no job the audience with a shallow
spectacle while milking them and Elvis
for every penny oh so it's a baz luhrman
biopic too got it got it are you an
Elvis historian kick rocks Daddy-o cause
this retelling of the King's life skips
the iconic MSG concert Infamous meeting
with Nixon and the time he died on the
toilet but if you're a history in a
music I mean the meeting with Nixon is
probably like the funniest and how can
you ignore that if you're making a bio
of him like federal drug agent yeah and
like his his rationale was that like
he's done so many drugs and he knows
from the inside all the Creeps in the
music industry that he's going to take
down with his karate and and so right
I I just assumed that he was like hey I
would like to get to the drugs sooner
than I already am so maybe if I'm
friends with the president then I get to
be VIP for drugs I get to go into the
seized FDA drug blocker and just to turn
the cameras off give me five minutes
yeah
uh and then yeah like more actors should
play Nixon I want to give every actor
out there who has any interest at all a
chance to play Nixon in something what a
fun role that's right that's really
funny Sam Rockwell's Nixon or something
I feel like this movie already is Nixon
yeah this movie would have been the best
would have been like uh all right I'm
gonna get Jim Carrey he's gonna do that
thing where he talks with his back from
Ace Ventura I'm like that Nixon
in a dual role
yes yes
oh man I want to see that Elvis too fast
come on
all right keep going you're a historian
of Music movie cliches get ready to walk
Hard through all the greatest hits like
nervous first performance with Mike V
back
in a haircut fairy
rising up the charts montage
[Music]
why don't you try one of these put the
pet back into your stick even a
supportive wife who stood by the artist
since the beginning though they leave
out the fact that she was 14 years old
when they met dude and I thought his
relationship with Mama was weird
uh Priscilla I don't know if she was a
producer but she definitely had like
approval over the script and story of
this one and that's always funny or fun
or at least just gives you an
interesting musical biopic when the
estate is involved because somebody
always comes off looking really good and
it's usually the subject and uh their
spouse like Bohemian Rhapsody where it
was like but Freddie Mercury we have to
stop partying we have to go home to our
wives and children
you've gone way too far the important
thing is our marriage I have to leave
your cork and [ __ ] party and we're
thinking this one in that scene with
Priscilla they're literally like I mean
I told Daddy all we do is sit around and
listen to records and they have like the
door wide open so it's obviously like
nothing is happening but the Elvis is
like Oh Maya your dad is so uptight it's
like no dude you're you're 14. you're a
14 year old girl yeah she's 14 and
you're the most famous man
you're dead very justifiable here you're
the villain in this scenario
all right
promise me baby so if you're ready for
the story of a beautiful naive Royal who
just wants to be part of their world
with a powerful voice that gets stolen
by a big evil con artist and someone
marries a teenager but you're also too
racist to believe that a mermaid could
be black then this is the live-action
film for you is what he's white he's
white though to get the analogy going
person would have to stab the kernel in
the chest with a boat at the end but
honestly that wouldn't have been out of
place in this movie because it's bonkers
it's like two minutes yeah
[Music]
starring
Eminem Origins Colonel Slanders barely
even close to approaching legal A Little
Less Conversation a little more action
my boy my boy my boy my boy my boy my
boy my boy my boy my boy my boy my boy
my boy my boy my boy my boy my boy my
boy oh my boy when Army hammers dates
builds a little soy sauce on her arm
and all the crotch shots
[Music]
Lord have mercy
featuring the music of Elvis uh pause
shout out to uh matatron
um or not X but he's he's our music guy
from before who is currently pursuing a
law degree so he doesn't have as much
time to do the full songs anymore
what a way stupid we tried to stop him
we begged him not to we did what we did
he was willing to put in some work over
the weekend to uh create that's my dick
for us so much appreciated so so the
first time I heard that I was already
like losing it and then when it goes
into the dick I was like okay I'm done
it's it's behind the scenes it's funny
because Spencer will message me things
like hey we need to make sure we pay
Matt because he did the or like make
sure you credit Matt because he did the
that's my dick song like in quotes or
something like that and I wouldn't have
heard it and I'll be like and then I'll
finally hear it I'll be like well I
don't know what I expected other than
exactly titled this yeah like I see the
invoice before I see the actual products
that my friends is that that's my dick
song The Honest Trailer uh scripted
biopic movie it'll be like the three of
us like peering into a shack at like Dr
Demento
like that's what inspired us as children
it's like Weird Al
oh yeah weirdo was my first cop
literally the first live show I saw and
uh for CD for me yeah I was single
digits and I had to leave because I
thought I started crying because he uh
cut a woman in half during Like a
Surgeon and I thought it was real
had to take me outside and explain to me
that he didn't actually saw that lady
moment
someday you'll write songs where you
replace the words with dick
really really Zoom forward it just
focuses through your eye until we come
back to now it's just like the Frozen
honest trailer like Rising through the
YouTube charts
good stuff all right keep going
hi everybody hi Dr Nick is that where Dr
Nick comes from it must be I'm thinking
about this yeah I somebody some Simpsons
writer knew that Elvis's drug doctor was
Doctor Doctor Nick I guarantee you
that's right yeah yeah good stuff
um all right uh there's a few things to
address right here right now one is that
uh our friend of the channel pitch
meeting
um they reached out for their 300th
episode uh if they could do a little
honest trailer for themselves and they
pitched some jokes but otherwise that's
uh uh Ryan George's whole uh production
he he did a an honest trailer for
himself on uh so go check that out on
Pitch me I think it's really funny
um came out really good yeah yeah yes
yeah I got that shared to me friends who
I don't even like like friends actually
sent that to me like did you see that
this happened and stuff like yeah we
were like yes yes yes but it was yeah it
was really cool it's amazing how many
more friends of mine are pitch meeting
fans in Australia fans
they probably don't send me honest
trailers for a reason that that would
make so yeah great stuff this week dude
yeah bro
have you seen this
um yes uh what else do we got going on
there are
uh Ryan what should we plug here
um and doors I forgot to put plugs in
it's my fault Ender starts tomorrow but
late because it's three episodes so I'm
gonna I don't man
yeah I don't want I don't want to come
in here until later yeah so what 1 p.m
two hours later than usual we're gonna
do Andrew through three and then it'll
go back to normal times every week after
that and then yeah yeah She-Hulk I think
uh Emma and Bailey are still doing rings
of power uh and twitch stuff on Thursday
with the fan club
um you and Carolyn just talked about
House of the Dragon yesterday if you
missed that check check that out
and there's an evolution of coming out
soon that people should be excited for
yeah yeah yeah I can nap sock a kid nap
sock uh deep on the rebellion and wow
it's like everything of the Rebellion
it's like the Ken Burns of Star Wars
it's great it really is oh so yeah
looking forward to that uh all right so
sweet um we have deleted scenes this
week or no Austin Butler delivers a
breakout performance as the king of
whitewashing black music
[Music]
fine fine go on and do me oh hound dog
you
me Colonel Thompson what the [ __ ] is
that is that Tom Hanks a family business
what voice is he doing I was just a boy
from Huntington West Virginia does the
real guy sound like that so I did my
part Elvis did his show and we were
lucky no I I'm sorry I just need to zag
this is just
that's a lot starring
getting Wiggly with it take the L that
don't impress me much Smells Like Teen
Spirit Austin's Powers Toy Story 4 is
strong the greatest snowman Priscilla
Queen of the insert the greatest snowman
Austin's powers and an international Man
of History white hot American singer
I ain't nothing but a snow job now
that's what I call Elvis
and there you have it
um
now that's because it was it was just a
mixtape the movie is a is a mixtape yeah
yeah
um all right let's go on with some
questions
um Adam Halbert says okay serious
question is Hank's great or terrible
depending whether he's taking this
seriously or is aware of how
cartoonish's performance is and I think
Lon you already addressed that excellent
uh point with Pinocchio and long coping
and then the Tom Hank's brain might be
full of holes right now yeah I don't
know man I don't know if it was just
this one in isolation I'd be like listen
he got into the the baz was there and
but at the sea it's it's it's it's
hitting our screens at the same time as
this ridiculous Pinocchio movie yeah in
which he sings the chorus Pinocchio holy
smokio
you could have said no right there
um
yeah I think
I got as far I got as far into that
Pinocchio movie as the Disney logo and
the horrifying Jiminy Cricket lowering
himself down and I was like nope nope
I'm watching something else I don't
know Cricket voice is also we could do a
whole 45 minutes on that well I think
we're gonna wait this little preview
there's like five Pinocchio movies out
or coming out uh within this year so I
think we'll do an end of the year
Pinocchio film wrap up on his trailer
because there's like oh that's so fun
that's great uh there's a lot
um okay
yeah yeah Shore versus Del Toro who you
got
um what am I gonna get to go out of my
um
is that him that's him right yeah okay
uh all right
who would each of your dream biopics be
about who would you choose to Star and
direct mine would be Nickelback with
Chad Kroger being played by Nick Cage
and directed by Lord and Miller and they
make that pretty funny but yeah do you
have a uh you have a biopic that you
would you'd like to see oh
um I mean musical or otherwise I guess
it could be anyone
that's always a fascinating character
there's a lot of fun movies about
different phases of his life I feel like
there's always more stuff to do there
and it was fun because he had kind of a
meta
you know like like he was already kind
of aware of his sort of public Persona
so I think he could have a lot of fun
with that most modern movies
um I don't know about necessarily A
biopic but I would love to see like a
90s grunge version of an Almost Famous
like I think that that would be a really
like kind of fun thing because that I'm
literally just combining two of my
favorite things yeah Seattle and Almost
Famous so and it's someone who works for
his Zine and like yeah exactly like spin
in the night yeah yeah I like that a lot
it would never happen but the the the
curdle Tom version of the Lauren
Michaels story like oh yeah like Lauren
Michael's getting the full or you know
or David Stern for the NBA of like yeah
you did a lot of good but man you had to
do a lot to do it but uh yeah kind of
surprising it'll probably be like after
Lauren officially retires yes early SNL
movie yeah yeah I mean if you're
represented right for like a bunch of
actors to play like young Bill Murray
Gilda Radner
and like that's what those actors those
that's no actors have done in other
movies like The David Wayne movies and
stuff um and the Lampoon movie they did
so it'd almost be kind of interesting
then see like food movies
so yeah but yeah that's kind of what I'm
based off of but yeah the Lauren Michael
story would be interesting especially if
you were a dictator like Tom Hanks is in
this movie like I am like salivating
over Jimmy Fallon uh I want like full I
want full buyers Dr Evil impression yes
yes
I am gonna go with Chet Hayes
um and I want to do a Chet Haze biopic
uh but I want it to be like um like uh
like being there or or some kind of like
filmmaking conceit where like there's
the world we see the world as it is and
the world inside Chet Hayes's head where
he's like in like you go back and forth
between what's actually happening like
in his brain he's in like Kingstown and
he's actually played by a Jamaican
played by a Jamaican actor yeah
okay there's got to be an available
Marley there has to be yeah yeah I think
you're both burned out Marley
uh all right the last one I'd pitch is
the Lonely Island writing and producing
their own biopic whether or not they
actually play him or not but like them
having control that's quote-unquote tell
their own story I feel like would be
super fun like about them making pop
stars yes or something like that but
like something where they are then going
back and almost like having other people
you know rat Daniel Radcliffe's playing
all of them or something fun I don't
know you know we've seen it yeah
uh let's see I think that
um
uh this one's interesting also a
challenge but Matan balinski asks how
would you insert the music biopic
cliches into ones about Eminem Oasis and
Nirvana or give it give me a cliched
musical moment for any one of those
bands
oh I mean Oasis is like they have like a
actual movie style Feud and yeah story
to them of like they're Brothers but
they love but they hate each other yeah
that would lend itself to film if anyone
cared about the music you could have a
lot of fun because Oasis there's there's
the me team of a guy picking up guitar
like now here's Wonder Woman the first
time they the first time they ever play
Wonderwall in concert in the film you
gotta you gotta hit that moment Noel
picks up the guitar like now here's
Wonderwall yeah you know
yeah that's definitely the big payoff of
wastes by okay
yeah um I mean Eminem already kind of
had his with that yeah so I don't yeah I
don't know if we want to do another spin
around that block um I like what Matan
adds with the uh Kurt Cobain got to
think about his whole life before going
on MTV Unplugged oh yeah no like him
walking up you see like we're watching
him pick the perfect perfect ratty
sweater yeah getting everything ready
while like in the back uh then then it
goes back to like him being a kid and
growing up in Aberdeen and yeah I see
the vision yeah
um nice all right well uh and then we'll
we'll close on this Billy Bristol s uh
what's your pick for the best uh artist
or musician biopic what's your favorite
do any of these work for you
I mean What's Love Got to Do With It is
probably still my favorite
um yeah just because and maybe it's
because it's like that one and the it's
not a biopic but it's that that Jackson
an American Dream I just like Angela
Bassett let's just let's just say that
let's say that it's like it's the best
yeah it's hard I feel like post Walk
Hard it's hard to go back and like give
these movies their flowers because that
movie nailed it so like it's such a
perfect sort of taked out of that genre
and how kind of ridiculously trophy it
is yeah
right after that there's so many amazing
music documentaries it's like their
lives are interesting enough and they
are like compelling and charismatic
enough or in fact they're so compelling
and charismatic that actors can't really
replicate whatever it is the musician
has usually yeah um so they usually
don't work yeah
through eight scenes of like you can't
walk the line
which is just the recreation of the
great like who remembers the scene from
Great Balls of Fire other than him
performing Great Balls of Fire because
even that uh uh even in that new Whitney
Houston biopic they immediately do the
first time performing feedback goes on
right
right it's like the same bit like all of
these stories story kind of similar
perform how close do they get to the
real thing you know like do they do they
absolutely nail it or is it like we
could tell it's a different person a
little bit and it's a little off yeah
it's a weird one weird genre
um uh Ryan chimes in with a very good
point in the chat uh asking for hype for
the Weird Al movie uh yes of course we
are yes of course yeah come on we have
souls uh that looks amazing um and I
will say as far as music biopics go
Straight Out of Compton minus the last
30 40 minutes I think is one is probably
my favorite
um that's when it got closer to the
present day and you could tell the
living guys got very involved and it
just became like a cameo
yeah it kind of loses this
but up until then man that was that what
I thought broke the mold and was was
good
you can tell that that kid can really
act because he's playing his father
flirting with his mother and he's able
to like do that that was the moment
where I was like this kid might be a
star it might not just be that he looks
like tall ice cube there you go
all right well uh with that we will we
will bid you a do
um and we will say good night
because we'll see you next week
perhaps in your dreams before then
that's all we're gonna say this week's
episode of honest trailers uh commentary
we'll see you next time thanks for
watching bye-bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign